hello everyone welcome to today's
webinar virus hunters i am michelle
ashton of leopards and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab room and brought to you by Abbott
molecular to learn more about our
sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license a question
box and click send will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit I now present today's
speaker dr. Michael G Berg the principal
scientist of infectious disease research
at Abbott Diagnostics for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. bernd you can now begin your
presentation
okay Thank You Michelle for the kind
introduction today I'll be taking our
listeners through our virus Discovery
Program describing the technology and
the challenges involved the capacity
we've built it a bit and then a brief
look at some of our recently identified
viruses
before delving into discovering new
viruses it's important to describe what
avid is doing to ensure that we reliably
detect old viruses particularly
blood-borne pathogens like HIV HPV and
HCV which are a constant moving target
due to mutations and recombination the
global surveillance program now 25 years
in the making is a research effort to
continually monitor viral sequence
diversity and the emergence of new
strains through collaborations in nearly
40 countries we've characterized over
70,000 specimens and with all this data
we have it neatly organized in a
searchable database so identification of
discordant samples and assembly of
panels with an array of genotypes or
mutations allow us to challenge our
assays and be confident that we are
detecting all infections
the key means by which we characterize
samples and correlate this to viral load
or antibody reactivity is through
sequencing rt-pcr combined with Sanger
sequencing has been the mainstay for
surveillance amplification of sub
genomic regions of diagnostic relevance
for example the gag Pol and envelope
genes of HIV can reveal mutations that
might impact detection as well as allow
us to phylogenetically determine the
subtype we are now leveraging
next-generation sequencing technology to
obtain the entire viral sequence in one
experiment
sequencing directly from Clint
samples poses several challenges which
I'll touch upon later but to increase
sensitivity many groups have used virus
specific approaches such as overlapping
amplicons to cover the entire genome
although the huge expanse of sequence
diversity makes this increasingly
difficult in terms of expecting it to
work on all strains the HIV smart method
which we devolved and depicted on the
left side of the slide is a universal
method that deploys tagged reverse
primers which are staggered about one to
two KB apart and regions conserved in
all HIV groups and this is to initiate
cDNA synthesis in a single reaction
viral sequences are then amplified with
smart primers found on each end of the
insert and converted to next Tara
libraries for Illumina sequencing we've
shown that all HIV groups can be
detected with this method and that it's
17 fold more sensitive than random
priming however for samples with titers
below log for copies per mil the
performance drops off pretty rapidly so
for these challenging samples we've
turned to target capture using x-gen
probes from IDT so if you look in the
middle of the slide note in orange that
for a log 3.5 sample the sequence depth
is low and genome coverage is incomplete
but with HIV x-gen enrichment shown in
blue the depth is nearly a thousand fold
greater and the entire genome is covered
the plot beneath that illustrates the
jump in coverage for several samples
tested with this comparison and so x-gen
yields sequence for samples with very
low titers that we would otherwise not
have even attempted on the right hand of
the slide probe sets covering the entire
known diversity for hepatitis B and
hepatitis Delta have been similarly
devised
and shown to also provide a huge boost
in NGS sensitivity for these viruses
so one of our recently published survey
efforts on more than 12,000 participants
in some southern Cameroon used a
combination of rt-pcr and NGS approaches
for HIV saying a sequencing of envelope
detected a wide range of subtypes
circulating recombinant forms and all
the groups while NGS helped us to
characterize only the seventeenth
documented group and strain and 24
similarly rare group o strains
most of the HPV infections were either
genotype a or e with NGS helping us to
determine the breakpoints of a rare AE
recombinant
or HCV mostly genotype for its less
prevalent in the region but found more
frequently and older men and then
finally for htlv while we only see this
in 1% of those tested we were able to
identify the fifth case ever of htlv 3
and obtain 80 percent of the genome
using next-gen sequencing
so to assist with this analysis of
numerous large data sets that we
generate for both Sanger and NGS our
team has been developing automated
pipelines and user interfaces for HIV
and HPV to enable the bench scientist to
standardize our output and increasing
efficiency in a few short minutes now
after uploading raw data files we'll get
an accounting of how many reads were
found for each virus will generate a
consensus sequence and learn the
identity of its closest relative we
generate coverage plots and phylogenetic
trees complete with bootstrap values we
are also now able to process hundreds of
datasets per week all with the push of a
button
if you'd like to learn more about the
avid global surveillance program I
encourage you to visit our website those
interested interested in partnering will
find an email address to contact us but
now that you have an appreciation for
the work avid is doing to stay ahead of
ongoing epidemics I'd like to shift
gears now and focus on our efforts to
anticipate the next
new pathogens are continually emerging
as a result of globalization
international travel military deployment
changes in the environment and
encroachment of humans into habitats of
animal reservoirs recently we've
witnessed the rapid spread around the
globe of SARS MERS Ebola and Zika our
virus discovery program is in place to
be prepared with diagnostic tools for
the next outbreak so we proactively
obtained specimens from patients with a
variety of diseases of unknown origin to
determine if known or completely novel
viruses are present to our knowledge we
are the only company engaged in this
type of work and this program exists as
evidence to our customers of our
commitment to ensure the safety of the
blood supply and bring them
best-in-class
infectious disease assays
traditional methods of virus detection
such as electron microscopy are either
labor intensive and requires specialized
skill set
while culturing is either difficult or
impossible for some viruses PCR and
serology also require a knowledge of the
sequence that it is you're looking for
but with the advent of genomics now this
offers a means to perform massively
parallel analysis in a sequence
independent manner
micro arrays like the viral chip shown
on the left are spotted with tens of
thousands of probes complementary to
conserved viral sequences from and they
provide the ability to hybridize nucleic
acids of an unknown sample and identify
which viral species or family might be
present but this technology was clicked
quickly eclipsed by next-gen sequencing
which yields the exact sequence and can
process numerous samples simultaneously
today there are several acute chronic
acute and chronic illnesses caused by
infectious agents that still go
undiagnosed examples of these include
upper respiratory tract infection
gastroenteritis encephalitis and
hepatitis just to name a few
this slide lists some of the previous
illnesses as well as other conditions
that are of interest to our program
while most diseases are likely related
to infections such as transfusion or
transplant transmitted agents we also
explore chronic conditions like
fibromyalgia or autoimmune diseases like
lupus with potential microbial origins
the utility of next-gen sequencing for
identification or discovery is really
predicated on the concept of meta
genomics or the ability to survey all
microorganisms simultaneously and that
includes bacteria parasites fungi and
viruses so starting with a clinical
sample such as blood plasma urine sputum
CSF we extract all the nucleic acid and
ideally recover both RNA and DNA then
using random primers to initiate cDNA
synthesis theoretically any sequence
will be reversed transcribed and that
includes reads derived from the host as
well as the invading agent
the sequence the library's inserts are
then reduced in size by fragmentation
and adapters are attached to ends to
permit binding to the sequence or flow
cell within these adapters are molecular
barcodes usually six to ten base pairs
in length which allow for multiplex
sequencing of numerous samples on a
single run the bottom half of the
diagram depicts the bioinformatics steps
involved and focuses on quality of reads
removing the host sequences and
taxonomically classifying the reads
matching to pathogens found in public
databases like GenBank the my seat is a
luminous bench top version which
produces approximately 40 million reads
per run but there are other models
available that produce orders of
magnitude greater throughput
following a total nucleic acid
extraction on our avid M mm instrument
we use unbiased primers either random
hexamers and a logo DT to drive reverse
transcription the second strand has been
copied with sequin ace enzyme and the
reactions are cleaned up on as I mul
spin column cDNA and double-stranded DNA
is then tagged mented with aluminous
next Tara XT kit this process fragments
the library and attaches the i5 and i7
adapters which are fused to the barcode
sequences we recommend that you use
unique barcodes on each end to
facilitate the multiplexing process as
well as reduce the phenomenon known as
barcode hopping
as I alluded to previously the challenge
of clinical samples is due to the fact
that viruses represent represent a very
small minority of the total reads
present in a sample typically the
majority of sequences are derived from
the host and the rest are related to
either Maitre method or matrix specific
background for the 1% or less that are
actually viruses many of these tend to
be commensal viruses like tor Tenno
virus or TB V virus C for this reason we
pre treat with benzoate to reduce host
background before extraction and then we
may often resort to target capture
methods after libraries are made to then
amplify viral sequences from already
made libraries
equally critical to meta genomics and
the discovery process is the
bioinformatics analysis over the last
decade we have partnered with dr.
Charles Chu at the University of
California San Francisco who is a world
leader in pathogen discovery Charles in
his lab developed a pipeline which they
named SERP II that uses in a liner
called snap which is orders of magnitude
faster than blasts and this removes
human sequences and quickly detects
whether there are known viruses bacteria
parasites or fungi present in the
samples and then reads without a match
in the NT database are then translated
in six frames and compared to a viral
protein database using the algorithm
known as rap search and this is used to
predict if a divergent or novel virus is
present the UCSF Abbott virus discovery
Center has used this successfully to
correctly diagnose a nearly fatal case
of neuro leptospirosis as well as to
characterize completely new viruses
including a rhabdo virus found to cause
hemorrhagic fever and a polyomavirus
causing acute diarrhea just to name a
few examples
in collaboration with Don Jensen and
Andrew Aronson at the University of
Chicago a cohort of 170 chronic liver
disease patients were screened at UCSF
using unbiased NGS in an effort to find
potentially new viral causes of
hepatitis the index patient in whom
viral sequences were found was a 70 year
old female that unfortunately died of
sepsis and resultant multi organ failure
and it turns out in fact that she was
HCV positive and potentially infected
after enrollment in this study and again
unfortunately she had failed
interferon treatment on the Left shown
in blue and green are the spikes in her
liver enzyme levels and in the red line
are her titers for hepatitis C it's also
of note that this patient had sickle
cell disease and received more than 70
blood transfusions took a single time
point drawn in 2008 of plasma to use for
NGS
Charles initially detected three NGS
reads with remote amino acid homology
less than sixty percent to simian Peggy
virus a or gvv a since the samples at
that time were pooled a dedicated NGS
run was performed on this sample alone
then using blast X to other Peggy virus
genomes to identify additional reads
configs were then generated by de novo
assembly next gaps were closed by PCR
and saying our sequencing and then in
panel D we show a coverage plot of the
combined NGS and saying or data which
essentially provided a draft genome
covering what ended up being 98% of the
genome
but to to cover our bases an independent
sample was sent to Abbott where I
obtained a quarter million reads that
covered and extended this draft genome
filling in remaining gaps and obtaining
the untranslated regions found at the
ends of the virus
new virus which we named human Peggy
virus 2 has a 10 KB genome that follows
the same basic structure of other
flaviviruses it has a 3,000 amino acid
poly protein precursor which is
translated and then subsequently
subsequently cleaved by host and viral
protease --es into the structural and
non-structural proteins
PEGI buyers - is highly divergent and
most closely related to Peggy virus's
found in both rats and bats while
certain conserved enzymatic proteins
like the NS 3 and NS 5b proteins can
exhibit upwards of 50% amino acid
identity to these and other species
overall the genome level identity is
less than 32%
using only the index case sequence
Abbott design primers and probes in the
NS 2 and s 3 region to design a first
generation cue PCR assay to identify new
strains of the virus we first began
screening in HCV positive plasma and
blood donors reasoning that these
high-risk groups or those multiple
transfused like the index case is where
we would expect to find others
identification of more are any positive
specimens and sequence characterization
by NGS demonstrated that this virus was
in fact not an artifact or a contaminant
since we found additional strains with
sequences that differed by about 6
percent once nearly a dozen strains were
identified at Abbott we designed an
improved triplex qPCR si for the M 2000
that detects human peggy fires 2 in two
regions here to ensure that we catch all
infections and then it detects G BB C in
a third channel to give us a picture of
the prevalence of this virus compared to
the only other known human pagi virus
again G BB C
in parallel a seer logic assay was
developed on the abbot architected
instrument here using biotin labeled
peptides of sequences predicted to
resign in either antigenic or surface
exposed regions of the poly protein free
peptide markers found in NS 3 NS 5 a and
a region spanning the NS for a B
cleavage site correlated strongly with
RNA positive specimens thus it appeared
that by remya persists in the presence
of antibodies
we screen more than 24
examples including a high-risk
populations such as those infected with
HIV and HPV as well as normal healthy
donors but we only found human Peggy
virus - are any positives in HCV
infected individuals similarly high
titer antibody responses often to more
than one peptide were found again only
in HCV positive samples there were
singly reactive specimens but they were
generally with low esta ce o--'s and
seem very infrequently in these other
populations
so to summarize h PG b2 is a rare
infection found in only one point two
percent of HCV co-infections at the same
time I'm at Kapoor and Ian Lipkin from
this same virus in haemophiliac and
transfusion transmitted cohorts and in
this case three of the four of them were
HCV positive and they named this same
virus human have had G virus one the
strains we've identified to date are all
93 to 94 percent identical at both the
nucleotide and protein levels Peggy - is
a blood-borne virus able to establish a
chronic infection and again is strongly
associated with HCV infection presumably
as a result of intravenous drug use
importantly the conclusions we have
arrived at have all been supported by
independent studies conducted in several
other countries
this experience with Peggy too helped us
to understand what pieces were needed to
develop an entire story and what would
be required to discover the next virus
at this end we said about building
capacity internally at avid we now have
all the instrumentation for library
preps and sequencing we've developed
methods for a variety of specimen
matrices we have the bioinformatics
solutions which are accessible to the
non programmer and the means to
cultivate new pathogens and our bsl-3
facility as well as a high-throughput
systems like an mm and architect to
develop new molecular and serologic
diagnostics another key piece not shown
here is at its global presence and our
ability to partner with customers blood
banks and academic institutions around
the world to source interesting samples
viral bacterial and parasitic infections
are detected here from a variety of
specimen types our refined methods
combined with the sir P pipeline can now
easily identify Zika virus in plasma
from a patient from the Dominican
Republic or a nose a Kamiel infection of
the Serratia marcescens bacteria found
in the be al the patient hospitalized in
colombia and finally peepal super
malaria in blood obtained from febrile
donors in Africa
it's essential that in each experiment
it be conducted in a consistent manner
and that we're assessing for the
sensitivity for viruses so before
extraction each sample is spiked with a
small foreign RNA to serve as an
internal control to measure recovery
throughout the entire process we
typically run eight samples together to
achieve approximately five million reads
per sample included among these is a
normal human plasma negative control and
a positive control that consists of nine
different viruses each diluted to log
four copies per mil the former negative
control tells us if a contaminant virus
sequence is present in the prep and
potentially all samples and the latter
gages our sensitivity for RNA or DNA
viruses large or small viruses surfy
also gives us a breakdown of the reads
which you can see are fairly consistent
from run to run in the study I'll
describe on the next slide it's also
important for us to show that we detect
tick-borne agents such as Borrelia
Bartonella anaplasma ehrlichia and birth
and Babesia also present it's similar
titers and that we can detect it with
this meta genomic approach
we've now sequence more than 150 samples
with line like symptoms fibromyalgia and
chronic fatigue looking for both known
and potentially new viruses or bacteria
that cause B symptoms in this process
several unexpected viruses were found
some with examples already in the
literature having association with these
symptoms we found two infected with
hepatitis C and two with human Peggy
virus 2 as well as another with
parvovirus b19 we continue to analyze
this data but we often wonder about the
significance of a few viral reads
present among millions and whether these
simply represent noise or are they an
indication of a low-level infection
to address this possibility we've turned
to twist Biosciences and viral probe set
which consists of more than 600,000
probes tiling over thousand human
viruses here we show the results from
metagenomic libraries of our positive
control each again with log four copies
and then compare it to pan viral
enriched libraries from the same sample
meta genomic libraries in black here
shown detect most of the viruses at this
low titer but with low coverage and
really only one to ten million one to
ten reads per million but by contrast
genome coverage jumps up considerably
with the target capture approach shown
in red some viruses like Edna virus
seven parvo be 19 and the herpes viruses
which were barely detectable with
metagenomic NGS now have twenty to sixty
percent genome coverage and more than
100 reads per million and unlike the
previous extant approach that looks
specifically at either HIV or HPV this
allows us to probe for any known virus
present at low levels in libraries
this still leaves us with the need to
detect divergent or previously
undiscovered viruses as expected the pan
viral probes on the previous slide
failed to enrich for human Peggy virus
to since none of the probes were
designed against the virus in that set
therefore we need to detect these solely
on the basis of similarity using
bioinformatics wrap search was mentioned
before and here's an example shown on
the left when the human Peggy virus to
reference sequence is not part of the
database queried it will reveal these
reads in a positive sample by the
thousands through homology to rodent bat
or simian Peggy virus a and then by
comparison in the adjacent Lane the
negative control water shows that this
is indeed a true hit and not background
since these reads for rodent and bat
Peggy virus are absent we've also been
developing another pipeline which we've
coined divert that further assists us in
our hunt for new viruses the presence of
many reads with highly significant eval
you score x' and mapping to multiple
genomic loci and related virus families
is generally a strong indication that a
new virus is present in a sample each of
these virus pipelines processes data
sets in a few minutes to hours when run
on our local server but we now have the
capability to run these and other
pipelines in the cloud
identifying individual reads is the
first step but generally only a subset
of sequences bearing resemblance to
regions of greatest conservation are
ultimately revealed the next step is to
assemble the puzzle pieces de novo using
sequences of related viruses as
essentially the picture on the box to
guide you
SERP II deploys abyss and minimal
algorithms while we also use de bruin
graphs assembler and CLC bio and space
to form context our customized NextEra
adapter removal algorithm helps us to
trim reads which we can then map reads
back to and extend in CLC bio using the
genome finishing module paired-end reads
indicated by the arrow in the figure
below help us to orient context relative
to each other an essential part of this
whole process is the constant vetting of
reads on our secure blast server here we
verify that we're not introducing human
or other non viral sequences into
context as we build out the viral genome
it also serves to verify that an open
reading frame and the alignment to the
related virus continues and finally we
can compile customized virus protein
databases to identify additional reads
with remote homology and this helps us
to fill in gaps
using these approaches we've recently
discovered a novel Pico bornavirus in a
patient hospitalized with lower
respiratory illness Pico beardo viruses
are small double-stranded RNA viruses
comprised of two genomic segments these
viruses are primarily associated with
diarrhea and gastroenteritis and are
known to infect a wide range of animal
hosts presumably by reassortment of
these segments segment one consists of
two open reading frames and our captured
sequence encoded on this RNA has only
37% amino acid identity to its nearest
sequence segment 2 encodes the RNA
dependent RNA polymerase and is more
conserved but this 2 only shares 64%
identity to the closest reference we are
now in the process of developing
molecular tools to identify other
strains and understand the prevalence of
this new potential pathogen
we have also recently discovered a novel
Bunya virus from an individual in africa
when your viruses are negative stranded
RNA viruses comprised of three genomic
segments these viruses are typically
vectored by ticks or mosquitoes and can
cause fevers or encephalitis we've
assembled nearly the entire genome and
found that the glycoprotein containing M
segments shares only 51% amino acid
identity to its nearest relative here
again we are in the process of
developing both molecular and serologic
tools and there is plenty left to learn
so with that I'm going to conclude and
thank you all for your attention and if
you have a mystery stored away in your
freezer or one that's ongoing at your
clinics and would like to partner with
avid I encourage you to email us at
global surveillance and Abbott comm so
that we can publish or discover publish
and innovate together
and last I'd like to thank my many
colleagues in a DD infectious disease
research who contributed to this work
and our many collaborators across the
globe at this time I'm happy to answer
any of your questions
thank you dr. Burke for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for let's get started okay our
first question we only have a small
amount of sample remaining how much
volume do you require for NGS okay
thanks Michelle so yes we would prefer a
minimum of 500 microliters which we'll
use for the extraction but if someone
can provide in excess of 1 mil ideal
because then if there's a positive
result from the next-gen sequencing we
can can follow up with additional steps
including developing a PCR test or
serology tests or culturing it so if if
you can have more than a milled it sigh
deal but even down to 200 microliters to
500 Michael a microliters we can work
with that
right thank you okay next question what
steps are involved in setting up a
collaborative research agreement with
Abbott
sure first you know reach out to us by
email and we'll discuss you know where
we have intersecting interests and then
we'll devise a protocol together where
we outline the sort of you know viruses
we might look at in a surveillance study
or if it were you know looking at
diseases of unknown origin and its
discovery in nature will will craft a
protocol along those same lines and then
it's up to then our licensing and each
institutions state tech transfer or
whoever their attorneys are to just kind
of you know decide on language but then
we will you know ideally if you're
sending us samples we'll we'll import
them or if they're you know within the
US it's much easier but that way we can
begin testing but yeah ultimately we
gotta just kind of communicate over
email or the phone and decide on what we
would like to work on
thank you okay next question how many
samples
can you multiplex together for probe
enrichment that really depends on the
viral loads of the samples you want to
and that will dictate whether you even
ought to do probe enrichment if it's
extremely high and you ought to have
gotten the full genome with our methods
by just the meta genomic approach but
we've we've applied this for our HIV and
heavy x-gen approach and and you know
multiplexed upwards of 25 to 30 samples
at one time and we're successful in
getting full genomes if not more than
50% so it can be done that way but then
there's other approaches where we're
looking at samples where we're very
confident there's nothing in there but
we'd like to you know push the envelope
and see how sensitive the enrichment can
be and and and in that case it becomes
more of a challenge to multiplex more
samples which are potentially all
negative and so ballpark though I would
say 20 is a good starting point
thank you okay next question do you know
if humans have a virus to can cause
hepatitis on its own without HCV
co-infection well I think that's still
an open question but at this point we're
seeing very few cases of PEGI virus -
without HCV co-infection so - you know
to find out whether someone has
hepatitis without this you know it is
difficult we have seen some antibody
positive for HCV that have cleared HCV
viral RNA so resolved infection for HCV
that has viremia for Peggy - but but
that's really been the exception and not
the rule so it's still an open question
we've tried culturing it on hepatocyte
sand in in a sample that was devoid of
HCV antibodies and this this was
unsuccessful though so we'll we'll still
see in the future
thank you again dr. Berg for your time
today and for your important research do
you have any final comments for our
audience sure and you know I just like
to take this opportunity to acknowledge
the people that were really deeply
involved in this work in particular
Julie Yamaguchi pioneered the x-gen and
the pan viral work that we showed Ken
for Berg working on the the fibromyalgia
and chronic fatigue and the new Pico
bornavirus Mary Rogers and Barb Harris
for their work and the HIV pipeline and
particularly Todd Meyer our violent form
at assist who's been leading the way
with with that pipeline as well as our
virus discovery pipelines and then and
finally Gavin clotty and John Hackett
for being for leading this effort
thank you again we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor Abbott
molecular for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go about
they thanked the audience for joining us
today and for their questions questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the undemanding
via the contact information be provided
at the time of registration lab routes
for you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye